Jourdan and Jojo make their big move he
has his backpack hi guys i'm lauren zima
bachelorette Jojo Fletcher and her
fiance Jordan Rogers moved him to Dallas
the two are wasting no time Jordan just
revealed the plans last week after their
engagement was announced we have a house
in Dallas we're moving in right after
this and now the pair has packed up his
things
oh and Jordan was shirtless for that
process Jordan we disagree now Jojo was
fully clothed but maybe not fully
helpful and as of 4:30 5:00 a.m. the
road trip began this might be brutal and
we're on Jordan is at the wheel of a
good old-fashioned moving truck this is
fun I gave is beautiful documenting it
all on snapchat the pair are making that
long drive from Nashville to Dallas
he has found Starbucks Dallas is where
Jojo has called home while Jordans
family lives in California now I am
loving Jojo and Jordan as a couple and
love that they did this move in such a
low heat normal way they may have been
on TV but means they're avoiding some
juba behavior that could have happened
what do you think of the big move let me
know on Twitter